well that's interesting because i
remember back to the talk shows of the
90s yeah Jenny Jones and Montel Williams
and then all of a sudden the Jerry
Springer and the Maury Povich started
doing a really sensationalistic stuff
and it seems like now we're seeing that
too and forgive me I'm from the San
Francisco Bay Area so do you think we'll
ever have stuff that has a higher
purpose to it you know that's maybe I
think we have it now I think you're not
watching the right content okay I think
that actually the really malicious
mean-spirited prank shows have you not
noticed a decline in those haven't once
I think people are just I think people
are getting a little bit tired of super-
humiliating content so we've evolved I
think I think we have I think we've
gotten past the part where just being
awful is not and as part of a spectacle
it's kind of those days are behind us I
know Morgan Spurlock did the day in the
life and he did one on Marc Maron it was
great right did went on a tear guada
from Banksy so he you know that one had
more much more of a higher purpose
because it was about these artists
following their you know day to day
lives so you think people are may be
done with some of the the the women
pushing each other into a pool and
saying mean things well I don't think
that I don't think that the naturally
occurring conflict is ever going to go
away what I'm talking about is a show
where someone's sitting in a car and a
guy dressed as a six-foot-tall alien
walks over Hill and rips the doors off
the car and starts dragging people off
into the night to the point where the
person has to spend time in therapy I
think those shows are behind us because
I think too much of it kind of made us
numb and now we want something else not
saying that the pendulum is swinging all
the way back over to all we're going to
be doing is super family friendly stuff
sure because people still like conflict
and people still like characters that
aren't necessarily admirable I talk
about him all the time Henry Jenkins
great media scholar one of the things
that he said was that audience you he
talks about the audience use of the
character
you hear a lot of times that people are
terrible role models in reality
television I'm like who are you as a
role model well are you a role model or
are you a cautionary tale are you a bad
example that is not to be followed in in
movies you know we talk a lot I mean I
was very funny I'm sorry now I'm the guy
that's good goes back and starts talking
over himself and not complete I should
have taken my three seconds I was an
event at an event last year John
O'Hurley at the end of speaking to a
group of people who were assembled at a
very prominent film school said at the
end of his speech he says and the one
thing I would tell all of you is don't
go into reality television it's so
negative it's like pulling the wings off
of flies and it's just a horrible and I
stood up in the middle of the audience
and just stuck my arms out like I just
was here for two days lecturing about
how to get into reality television
people don't get that there's a lot of
really great stuff and I don't think
that they use that label reality
television for it I think it's all it's
a you know it's a documentary series
into this it's of that I'm sorry it's
reality television it's reality
television just because people aren't
clocking each other over the head with
pots or pans or whatever it doesn't mean
that you lose the label reality
television if the phrase reality
television disappeared tomorrow and we
started judging it as you know factual
or authentic or some other word I think
that people would get away from
constantly damning the stuff that's a
little bit more pronounced well I like
what you said also to it could be an
example of a cautionary tale you know
doesn't have to be well this person is a
great example a pillar of their
community would also be well this is
what happens when let's just take the
example of Joe Millionaire which is
something I regurgitate all the time but
I love the show and it got me back into
watching TV for a short time but it's a
perfect example of you know women
fighting over a man and
really knowing who he was I just thought
he was one thing and again perfect
example of maybe how people should sort
of look at themselves so obviously
there's a market for this because if you
know going back to what our person on
Twitter said you know how can you be a
part of this there's a market for it yes
and I would also recommend to anybody
who is interested in reality television
I'm I'm not a defender of the low end
material I don't just say well you know
all reality television is is fantastic
there is an incredible book that was
written by a feminist media scholar her
name is Jennifer Posner the book is
called reality bites back it is a it's a
real takedown of how we portray women
and media how we portray minorities and
reality shows one of the things I think
reality shows do well is I think you
find more cast diversity in reality
television than you find a regular
programming the problem is a lot of the
show's still you have the whole princess
myth is still all over the place like oh
I just got to meet a man if I could just
meet a man all the dating shows it's the
same thing there's a lot that we can
work on and you know jennifer and I talk
periodically about the things that we
would like to see change in reality
television so that we can be a little
bit more evolved and kind of get
ourselves out of you know those old
those old stories but but in order to be
involved you have to the old thing they
say vote with your remote right and then
obviously follow the good stuff
you